jordon Woods's mama is speaking out and
defending her daughter on Sunday
Elizabeth woods took to Instagram to
address people who are selling merch
inspired by Jordans read Table Talk
interview where she broke her silence
about allegations that Tristan Thompson
cheated on Khloe Kardashian with her I'm
no homewrecker you remember the sit-down
I'm talking about it's literally all the
internet could talk about for days
I never was try to steal someone's man
anyway Elizabeth took to Instagram to
post this pic of a pillow and a pic of a
t-shirt with Jordans face on it
alongside a quote from her interview
reading I don't need your situation I
don't need your situation okay so that
actually is pretty funny but Elizabeth
she's not amused she captioned the pic
quote if you are aware of any companies
selling merchandise and trying to
benefit from our situation please tag
them below we would like for the world
to know that we have not authorized any
of this and have not profited from any
of these sales whatsoever thank you for
all the support and love hashtag team I
got this Jordan and her mama have been
spending some time together in London
where the 21 year old is promoting her
lash line after alerting fans of the
unauthorized merch she shared several
selfies from their time across the pond
Jordan was also active on social media
this weekend posting a message about
being quote blessed alongside this pic
of herself in a swimsuit because nothing
says blessed like swimwear JK she
captioned the shot quote morning swim
sometimes you have to take a step back
to remind yourself how blessed you are
to wake up and see another day while
Jordan is keeping her distance from the
Kardashian generous for now her mom
recently left a little love for Kylie in
the comments section of this post that's
the beauty moguls baby girl stormy and
those are three heart emojis from
Elizabeth as for the future of Kylie and
Jordans friendship a source tells ety
quote kylie is still figuring out where
Jordan fits into her life and the
biggest reason is because
Kylie wants to respect her sister Khloe
Khloe was initially irate at Jordan and
wanted nothing to do with her ever again
however Khloe is a forgiving person and
she's just trying to see if she can get
over being hurt by someone she
considered a sister and it looks like
the drama will all unfold on this season
of Keeping Up with the Kardashians I'm
not just a TV show like this is my life
sometimes the world forgets just to be
kind that we're all going through
something maybe just be a little more
understanding because it sucks a source
tells us Koko is doing much better and
is fully focused on her daughter do you
love yourself do you say I'm so
beautiful look see I am so happy yes I
love myself quote Chloe is really
enjoying the single life and spending
time with her favorite person in the
world true she still feels betrayed by
Tristan but she isn't allowing that to
affect her happiness any longer Chloe
loves with all of her heart and gave
Tristan another chance but that
relationship is over for good Chloe's
taking time to be single enjoy her
friends and family and focus on business
all right guys I'm just gonna go on
record and say it Chloe is my favorite
Kardashian and of course we'll be here
to keep you up to date on all things
Coco so make sure to keep it locked on
ET until next time I'm Holly Stephens
bye for now
[Music]